so last we spoke um which was for stuber
you were telling me how you were like
ready to go over to the suicide squad
and then i read you ended up passing
on that role for army of the dead yeah
how tough was that decision and what was
the thing that swayed you in the
direction of army of the dead
um the decision was heartbreaking the
conversation with james gunn was
one of the hardest things i've ever had
to do in my career because this is
this is a man who is not only a friend
but this is a man who
had faith in me and believed in me when
not a lot of people did and he not only
changed the trajectory of
my career but he also trained changed
the trajectory of my life because he had
faith in me
um so to go to him and tell him that i
can't do
i can't do this film and i can't do the
role that he wrote for me was just
i mean it was so hard it just it really
hurts my heart even thinking about
having this conversation
so at the time i just you know it was a
supporting role
and a great film but i was really just i
was doing it because it was
with james gunn i just wanted to work
with my friend whereas
army of the dead and had so many things
in it that would just
advance my career it was a lead role it
was
uh for netflix who i wanted to build a
relationship with
it was a great role where i'd be able to
add a lot of
emotion and depth to the character but
was also working with zack snyder
which is a director who was a director
that i had pursued for years i'd wanted
to work with zach for years long before
i even met zach
but when i did meet him we were trying
to get this other project up and running
for
for like two years before army of the
dead was even a mention in a
conversation
so just with all those weighing factors
i just uh i decided on army of the dead
and then i had the conversation with
james
and james couldn't have been any more
supportive i mean he was so supportive
which made me love him even more because
he understood not only did he understand
the decision that i was that i made
but he also took a sense of pride
that he got me to the position where
i was i was forced to make decisions
like that like he had everything to do
with getting
you know me to that position where i was
there in that position where i had to
choose between films and i was in that
position because of him
yeah that's a good place to be congrats
is there anything you can reveal at this
point of like what that role was or you
know what i'd say
i just wouldn't say because i would feel
like it would be
doing a disservice to the actor who
ended up in the role and i
i don't wanna i don't want to ever make
it seem like he didn't earn that role
because you know he did he earned that
role in his uh he's i'm sure he's going
to crush it
and i would i i just wouldn't do that
disservice to him or
or the film or james but uh yeah there
was a role in it for me i wish i could
have done it but it's just scheduling
wise it just wouldn't have worked out